ABOUT DOSSIER ABOUT THE
ELECTION.
THIS IS CORRUPTION AT THE
HIGHEST LEVEL.
SO MUCH TO GET TO TONIGHT.
JOIN US WITH REACTION
SABASTIAN GORKA AND SARAH
CARTER AND LEGAL ANALYST GREG
JERRIC.
ON TOP OF THE VICIOUS
BLOOMENTHAL THING, WE NOW HAVE
FBI, SARAH CARTER, LITERALLY
TELLING, THIS IS NEW TO ME,
THE GUY THAT IS PAYING FOR
RUSSIAN LIES, SOLACIOUS
DETAILS ON CANDIDATE TO FIX
ELECTION WITH PHONEELECTION WITN
PROPAGANDA THEY’RE GIVING HIM
INFORMATION?
>> I THINK THAT’S INCREDIBLE.
YOU WOULD THINK THE FBI WOULD
BE CLOSE HOLED ABOUT THEIR
INVESTIGATION BEFORE SHARING
THAT.
OBVIOUSLY WITH EXBRITISH SPY
WORKING FOR FUSION GPS AND
PAID BY DNC AND HILLARY
CLINTON CAMPAIGN IS SHUNNED.
THE FBI USUALLY DOES NOT SHARE
INFORMATION WITH PEOPLE THAT
THEY’RE INTERVIEWING AND IF
STEEL DELIVERING INFORMATION
TO THE FBI IT SHOULD BE THE
FBI QUESTIONING STEEL NOT
STEEL QUESTIONING FBI.
I THINK WHAT IT INTERESTING TO
ME IS AFTER STEEL GOT THIS
INFORMATION WHERE DID STEEL
OWE GO WITH IT?
THIS IS A QUESTION THAT NEEDS
TO BE ANSWERED?
DID STEEL APPROACH
PAPADOPOULOS AND HOW MUCH
INFORMATION DID HE GET ON
GEORGE PAPADOPOULOS AND THOSE
ARE QUESTIONS THAT STILL NEED
TO BE ANSWERED.
>> GREAT CHAIR FROM THE LEGAL
SIDE OF THIS DO YOU SEE ANY
LEGAL ISSUES, YOU HAVE BEEN
POINTING OUT YOU HAVE FOUR
LEVELS DEEP OF HEARSAY THAT
WOULD NEVER BE ACCEPTED IN ANY
COURT.
>> YOU KNOW THIS JUST UNDER
SCORES FBI WAS POLITICALLY
MOTIVATED TO DAMAGE TRUMP.
THEY’RE MEETING WITH STEEL AND
TRYING TO CONNECT THE DOTS
WITH PAPADOPOULOS AND THEY’RE
OFFERING TO PAY MONEY TO STEEL
TO CONTINUE TO DIG DIRT ON
DONALD TRUMP.
AND THEY BECAME IN A WAY, JUST
A POLITICAL ARM OF THE
DEMOCRATIC NATIONAL COMMITTEE
AND TRUMP CAMPAIGN AFTER THE
FBI CLEARED FOR POLITICAL
REASONS, HILLARY CLINTON IN
THE EMAIL SCANDAL AND THEN
LAUNCHED A POLITICAL
CONVENIENT DEBATE TO FRAME
TRUMP OVER RUSSIAN COLLUSION
WITHOUT CIN TY LLA OFWITHOUT CIF
EVIDENCE.
>> SO SHE FIXED THE PRIMARY
WITH BERNIE SANDERS.
AND SHE HAD THE LEGAL ISSUES
SO SHE COULD STAY IN THE GAME.
SHE HAD THE FBI DIRECTOR AND
PETER STRUCK WHO HATES THE
TRUMP AND LOVES HILLARY FIX IT
SO THEY CAN KEEP WORKING.
FELONYFELONIES WERE COMMITTED MS
HANDLEHANDLING CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION, ET CETERA.
AND THEN WE LITERALLY HAVE
THAT FAKE DOSSIER USED TO FIX
THE GENERAL ELECTION AND THEN
IT’S USED FOR A WARRANT
AGAINST THE THE OPPOSING
CANDIDATE IN ELECTION YEAR AND
IT’S USED TO SURVEILLANCE THEN
A PRESIDENT-ELECT AND HISA PRESS
TEAM.
>> AND SHAWN, I’M A LEGAL
IMMIGRANT TO THIS COUNTRY AND
PROUD TO BE AMERICAN.
I’M ASHAMED AND HORIFIED BY
EVERYTHING WE ARE LEARNING
EVERY DAY FROM SARAH, FROM
COLLEAGUE JOHN, FROM YOU,COLLEA,
GREG, AND JEFF FLAKE SHOULD BE
CONCERNED WITH THE TACTICS OF
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION, NOT
INSULTING THIS PRESIDENT WHO
LOVED HIS COUNTRY.
WHAT WE ARE SEEING IS
SYSTEMATIC TARGETING OF
POLITICAL ADD SAYREYES USING
TRUMP PUMP INTELLIGENCE FILES
FULL OF PROPAGANDA AND USING
DOMESTIC SURVEILLANCE.
WE HAVE TO USE THAT PHRASE,
SHAWN.
IT’S DOMESTIC SURVEILLANCE FOR
POLITICAL PURPOSES AGAINST
PEOPLE WHO ARE RUNNING AGAINST
THEM AS THEIR POLITICAL
OPPONENTS AND THAT’S WHAT’S
COMMUNIST AND AUTHOR TEARIAN
REGIMES NOW DO.
>> WE NOW KNOW THAT THE DOJ
HAD TO RELEASE THE DOCUMENTS
THAT THE FBI SURPRISED THEY
DID IT LAST MINUTE.
ROSENSTEIN TRIED TO FREV ENTER
AND GOES TO PAUL RYAN’S OFFICE
AND BEGS HIM NOT TO DO IT
WE’RE GETTING INSIGHT TO WHAT
WE LEARN NEXT WEEK.
SARAH CARTER, WHAT ARE YOU
HEARING.
>> EXTENSIVE FIZA ABUSE.
WHAT SEBASTIAN BROUGHT UP IS
IMPORTANT.
WE HAVE TO LOOK AT WHAT TYPE
OF SURE VAIMEN WAS CON DUGED
AND WHAT EVIDENCE TESTIFED TO
OBTAIN TWOORNTS ACTUALLY SPY
ON MEMBERS.
>> BUT THE DOSSIER WAS USED
AND FBI IS COLLABORATING WITH
THE GUY GETTING THE PHONETHE GUY
RUSSIAN PROPAGANDA YOU CANNOT
MAKE UP.  NO YOU CANNOT AND
BYRON YORK BROUGHT UP
INTERESTING NAKTS HIS COLUMN
TODAY.
THE FACT THAT STEEL COULD HAVE
BEEN DOING SEPARATE REPORTS,
OTHER REPORTS, OTHER THAN THE
DOSSIER.
>>EN AND WE SUSPECT HE WAS
PAID.
>> THEY SUSPECT HE WAS PAID
AND HE HAD A CLOSE
RELATIONSHIP WITH MEMBERS OF
THE STATE DEPARTMENT.
SO THIS IS SOMETHING THAT IS
BEING INVESTIGATED.
>> YOU KNOW, WHEN YOU HIRE A
SPY WHO IS TRAINED IN LIES AND
DECEPTION, WHO RELIES ON
RUSSIAN SPIES TRAINED IN LIES
AND DECEPTIONS YOU GET NOTHING
BUT LIES AND DECEPTIONS AND
THAT’S THE BASIS EVER THE
DOSSIER AND FOR THE FBI TO
BELIEVE THIS DOCUMENT, WHICH
ON ITS FACE IS FICTITIOUS, IS
ABUSE OF POWER.
>> AND THEY SHOULD HAVE NEVER
LOOKED AT IT THEY WENT TO A
JUDGE TO GET A WARRANT TO SPY.
USE A FAKE --
>> I WANT TO HEAR FROM THAT
JUDGE.
NO JUDGE I KNOW LIKES BELIED
TO.
>> OKAY.
LAST -- SO WE HAVE THE FAKE
NEWS AWARDS RELEASED TONIGHT.
SEBASTIAN GORKA IT’S NOT ONLY
REPORTS THEY GET WRONG IT’S
STORIES THEY WILL NOT COVER.
THESE STORIES AND I SEE
NOTHING BUT EGG ALL OVER THEIR
FACE COMING.
>> I AM SO -- IT’S SO
MAGNAMOUS TO PUT RUSSIAN
COLLUSION AT THE BOTTOM ONLY
OF THE LIST.
NOT PAUL DRUGMAN THAT
LAUGHABLE INDIVIDUAL SHOULD BE
AT THE TOP OF THE LIST.
I’M GLAD YOU HAVE A SENSE OF
HUMOR.
50 MINUTES ON WHAT THE
PRESIDENT’S BELT SIZE IT AND
WHETHER HE HAS TWO SCOOPS.
IT’S A PARAGDY OF MEDIA SHAWN